So now that we have seen how the 1-BIT History works, Let's do a quiz about
that. So we have 1-aof history and a
2-bit counter per history. And the pattern we
will try to predict is the not-taken, not-taken,
taken and then that repeats. This is a
regular expression, so BIT match is not-taken, not-taken,
taken, not-taken, not-taken, taken, etc. The 1-bit history,
is 0 at the beginning. The 2- BIT counters both start at the strong
not taken state. And the question for you is, after 100 repetitions of this
pattern, so there are 300 outcomes. NNT, and that repeats 100 times. What is the
overall number of mispredictions that we will have seen? Write that number here.